welcome
thanks for having me
um I just want to start the interview
off
because we just had this
um
hypothetical situation where I was
asking my boy because Millie's came in
and he has a pretty strong Boston accent
for the most part right
and
can you kind of like break down to me
like well one you don't have like a
crazy Boston accent
but like do you have friends that are
like women that have a hard time like
finding good men because they sound like
like oh yeah [__] Tom [__] Brady
they smoke cigarettes like I just I just
feel like if I grew up in Boston
and a girl talk like you know Millies or
like slain you know I'd be Judy yeah
like oh my God come here honey go get
the [__] calm a little [__] drunk
over here like I just feel like it'd be
like a turn off so like you have friends
that run into that I don't have any
friends that talk like that but it's
just like some of my friends moms okay
or like you know God bless their
husbands maybe even sometimes my mom
sounds like that sometimes it's like an
older
like I feel like you know white busted
woman thing yeah it's like the car the
bar the star yeah it's like fine let's
go five talk like that yeah yeah like
that [__] Tom Brady I love him he's a
buck but I [__] love him still I love
it it's his own thing yeah for sure do
you still do you find yourself still
rooting for Tom well he's retired now
but were you rooting for Tom when he was
over in Tampa Bay
um I wouldn't say like
I wouldn't say like rooting for him but
um like I definitely think he has like a
warm place in every Bostonian or
Massachusetts person's heart yes it
should yeah because all he's done for
the Patriots I think about that scene in
Ted 2 where Ted like sneaks into his
house to steal his car yes and I was
like yeah I'm sure a lot of people in
Boston would have done so weird
great movie by the great Boston yeah Ted
is an amazing movie they're they're
doing a TV show have you heard no I
didn't hear that they're like all series
no way yeah it should be good I hope I
could be in it shout out to Ted like
calling me well I want to say congrats
because you're like turned into like a
Bonafide Superstar oh thank you so much
and you've had like a really long
journey in this music industry you've
been through deals where you know
certain people didn't get it and you've
just kind of just transformed into like
uh one of the you know artists on The
Forefront of this Rapture so
congratulations I appreciate you a lot
thank you
um have you noticed like besides you
know obviously you're doing a lot of
shows you're doing a lot of festivals I
see you doing clubs you're in Vegas you
got you have Vegas residency right now
yeah I have um I have one with dress
right now uh before dress we did Jewel
and hakkasan so Tau group nah but like
have you noticed like for you was there
anything that changed
in terms of like where you started to
kind of see like things finally really
like work out in a big way
like where in terms of like were you
like doing anything differently or was
it just like finally the kind of the
Stars like aligned you know I think it's
a little bit of both I think uh when
every every time you see like an artist
have a moment I think there's like a
wonderful team behind the scenes like
that's helping them be great and I also
think that the stars are aligning
um and what I've learned through those
moments is just to like be way more
confident with whatever it is I'm doing
and just be sure of it before I press go
because then it's like it's foolproof
for sure do you because I feel like
there was like a moment where
you had gotten off of RCA because you
were on RCA for a while yeah like four
and a half years maybe
um and then the rust record happened yes
and then I feel like after that it was
just over after that has been kind of
busy because we well actually it was
crazy because the best on Earth happened
and then the pandemic hit so we weren't
really like able to work
um best on earth like in the clubs when
it first came out we didn't even end up
performing it together until a year
later right so uh that changes things I
think as well
um there's a lot of songs that I think
would have hit like in a different way
had we been able to be outside and has
had the stars and learned at that time
but either way I'm super grateful for
how it all turned out because I'm just
like
so blown away like you your plans are
never going to be as good as God's plans
for real yeah I think like I was just
like thinking like damn you got a record
with Nikki and a record with J Cole like
two of the greatest of all time crazy
right yeah like do you ever like look
back and just think like damn the last
two and a half years have been like
kind of surreal like I gotta kind of do
you appreciate it yes absolutely oh my
goodness like everybody that knows me
knows like I'm heavy on prayer like I
talked to God like a million times a day
and I'm just super grateful like I'm one
of those people that I I've seen so many
moments like come and go for me so now
I'm learning to just be like way more
present in those moments and appreciate
them for what they are and not like I
seek no expectations when I put music
out I just be like all right I'm gonna
put this out and whatever happens
happens and it's always some amazing
stuff that happens and so I'm always
like
shocks me right